I'm not here to tell you today that your breath stinks.
What I am here to share with you today is the best technique that we have found to cure
bad breath.
We're going to keep it short to the point so you can grasp the information and put it
to use in your own daily world hygiene habits.
So bad breath is caused by specific types of bacteria in the mouth.
We call these bacteria bad bugs because they're also responsible for gum disease and tooth decay
in the mouth.
A couple of points I want to bring up about the bad bugs and I'll show you the technique.
First of all, these bad bugs lay down a scum wherever they live.
They do this for a couple of reasons.
First of all, they lay down this scum in order to cling to or attach to whatever they're
living on.
So whether it's on the tooth surface or on the back of your tongue or wherever they lay down
the scum to attach themselves.
The second is to be able to create a low oxygen or what's called an anaerobic environment.
You see these bad bugs really thrive in low oxygen environments.
That's an important key when we look at the technique that we have here in order to rid
our mouths of bad breath.
Step 1.
Scrape your tongue with something like a tongue scraper, spoon, or a brush.
Really anything you can effectively remove the scum off the tongue with will work.
Well almost anything.
Step 2.
Now that we've removed the scum that keeps the bad bugs in a low oxygen environment, we
can now easily kill the bad bugs simply by brushing some antimicrobial solution over
the surface of the tongue.
An alternative to brushing an antimicrobial solution onto the back of the tongue is to put
a couple of drops of an antimicrobial into a cup of water and swish in gargle thereby still
getting it onto the back of the tongue.
The second step, using the second step of applying the antimicrobial on the toothbrush or
in a form of a gargle, is huge to really knock down the populations of bad bugs in your
mouth and really reduce the risk of bad breath.
We use the brushing blend as the antimicrobial after scraping our tongue, whether it's on
our toothbrush or a drop or two in the gargle cup to be able to swish with after scraping
the tongue, because it does a fabulous job of killing the bacteria that causes tooth decay,
gum disease, and bad breath, while it supports the gum tissue to heal better by increasing
blood flow to the gum tissue.
Make sure that you use a safe antimicrobial, it's actually really important.
Chlorine is an antimicrobial, but I'm not saying to go chlorine on your tongue.
If you're going to gargle with something, be very, very mindful that it's not loaded with
poisons or artificial dyes and funky junk in your system or alcohols because alcohol really
dries out the mouth and lowers saliva production and that increases the bad bugs that causes
bad breath.
So make sure you use a safe antimicrobial.
There's the technique we hope it helps, holler with any questions, we're here to help you
take control of your oral health.
Thank you.
Or our wellness, bright smiles, healthy gums, and fresh breath without all the other stuff.